plenty of things happening in the nfl as
always and let's get right into it the
guy who was the mvp of the super bowl
that the eagles won fewer than three
years ago now the starting quarterback
for the chicago bears it was a rough
night last night for the bears for the
offense which was dreadful they had a
chance to win the game
theoretically they had the ball they had
about a minute and on first and down
first and ten excuse me
the defense engulfed nick foles he got
rid of the ball as he was falling to the
ground he hit the ground hard he was
laying there motionless it looks serious
he was carted off it turns out shireen
he is day to day
with a hip slash
gluteus
injury which
in layman's terms he
broke his ass potentially although it
may not be broken it's day to day now i
fell down the steps last christmas day
what a present that was and broke my ass
so
i know how it feels to be day to day
walking around with a broken butt but uh
foles it could have been worse it looked
like his back it looked like his
shoulder
day to day and they have a bye week
there's optimism shireen he'll be good
to go when they come out of the bye and
basically the season's on the line when
they go to green bay next sunday night
thanksgiving weekend to take on the
packers
yeah when i saw that mike i thought it
was serious or more serious than what it
has turned out to be i mean i thought
this might be a season-ending thing and
they are very fortunate nick foles is
very fortunate that that's all it is and
when i say that's all it is football
players and i tweeted this the other day
football players by definition are tough
and don't ever question the toughness of
a football player they play through a
lot of stuff and when you hear turf toe
when you hear hip flexor when you hear
any of those things
they hurt and those guys play through
those injuries and it is amazing when
they get back on the field and he's
going to be in a lot of pain i don't
think there's any doubt about that
they'll shoot him up the best they can
when he does get back out there but
these guys are tough and he's tough and
and this isn't the last fortunately that
we've seen of nick foles this year
i remember the first time i ever heard
the turf toe diagnosis it was franco
harris in the 70s and i remember
thinking
that really doesn't sound bad turf toe
like
okay
like
walk it off and you'll be fine
but but yeah extremely painful because
it's your big toe it's your toe on which
you push off and it gets all the force
of your body as you run away and foles
is completely fearless when it comes to
standing in the pocket and taking
whatever comes his way and he's kind of
lanky
and it looks like he's going to get
injured every time he gets hit so of all
quarterbacks i think he's got even more
courage than most you don't see him
collapse like the proverbial house of
cards and avoid contact he stands in
there takes the big throw his first
touchdown last year with the jaguars in
his debut he got hit hard as he let go
of the ball and had a broken collar bone
and missed several weeks so he's
fearless to a fault and uh yeah we're
not doubting that at all now the
question becomes given how bad this team
suddenly is they were five and one
before hitting their current four-game
losing streak culminating in last
night's loss to the vikings but the
offense really was abysmal they got to a
point where they're just giving it to
cordell patterson on every play because
he seemed to be the only one who was
trying hard late in the game should they
stick with foals
or
if mitchell trubisky's shoulder is
healed in 12 days go back to him shireen
well you know i've said a lot mike you
and i kind of sort of disagree on nick
foles that he is one of the best backups
in my mind with real moral and nfl
history but he's not a starting
quarterback and he's never started more
than 11 games in a season and i think
he's a really good backup and and the
stats barrett i mean he's got an 81
passer rating which is ahead of only the
likes of cam newton dwayne haskins
daniel jones carson wentzman you get the
idea it's not very good he's 27th in the
nfl he has not played very well the team
is two and five with him as a
quarterback now having said all that i
don't know that they're any better off
with mitchell trubisky they were 3-0
with him but
i think they've got a quarterback
problem frankly in chicago i don't know
that it matters who they play i don't
think know that it makes a difference
but they've got to address the
quarterback position at the end of the
year
yeah and uh it's silly for me to think
that this would be a perfect opportunity
to bring in colin kaepernick and give
him a shot when week 12 rolls around
i remember vividly the way that colin
kaepernick bedeviled the sanford oh the
green bay packers when he was with the
san francisco 49ers way back when a game
in
lambeau field in the postseason where he
beat them and then there was a game in
san francisco where he set the
postseason record for quarterback
rushing in a single game but that's it's
not going to happen it's not going to
happen even though it should even though
he'd be a better option right now than
foals or trubisky it's not going to
happen and i'm starting to come around
on false i i hate to say it because i
love a great story and nothing would be
better than foles
playing on a regular basis like he did
that year that that it all fell together
but i think for him
it's kind of a tebow mania
kind of a slumdog millionaire where the
planets line up just right
and it all falls together just perfectly
once in a hundred years and it does it
for him in the playoffs like there's
something that comes over him and one of
the reasons why i'm starting to agree
with you last night they get the
turnover on the first drive kyle rudolph
fumbles loses the fumble for the first
time in his career and what does nick
falls do he's got a wide open guy with
the proverbial red sea parted in front
of him
no nothing to get in his way and he's
got anthony miller wide open
and he misses him and the ball pops up
in the air and harrison smith intercepts
it so you know you can't just turn that
on when the season's on the line when
you're in single elimination you got to
be that way all the time and i i hate to
say it but i'm i'm starting to agree
that maybe just maybe
nick foles caught lightning in a bottle
and almost caught it again in 2018 when
he nearly upset the saints as
quarterback for the eagles when carson
once was injured but
i i don't know i i that's my convoluted
way of saying you may be right and i may
be wrong
hey i won that one maybe yeah but i
would love to see i'm like you i would
false is a great story i would love to
see him do well i just haven't seen him
from him as a full-time starter and
that's all i'm saying and there's a
reason he's been with as many teams as
he's been with but do i want him on my
team as a backup absolutely i want him
on my team i just don't want him
starting every week
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports